donc je souhaite dans ces préliminaires
appelés un petit peu des points
importants sur ce qu'est la douleur
chronique donc elle affecte un effet 12
millions de nos concitoyens et peut
toucher n'importe qui à n'importe quel
âge de la vie ça peut être nos enfants
ça peut être notre parent la douleur
chronique affecte non seulement la santé
physique mais aussi le bien-être
émotionnel les relations
interpersonnelles la capacité à
travailler elle peut entraîner une
détresse psychologique une dépression
une anxiété une diminution de la qualité
de vie globale donc c'est pour ça que la
douleur chronique est une véritable
maladie elle va s'installer de façon
insidieuse elle débute souvent par une
douleur aiguë à la suite d'un
traumatisme de la vie une maladie ou une
vulnérabilité physique ou psychique mal
prise en charge et elle prend de la
place beaucoup de place de plus en plus
elle se répercute sur le sommeil
l'humeur la vie professionnelle et
familiale elle pèse énormément sur la
société entière et puis d'ailleurs il
faut savoir que depuis 2019 la douleur
chronique sont classées comme une
maladie à part entière par
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé
alors oui la douleur chronique est une
maladie apparentière au même titre que
la dépression ou les maladies
cardiovasculaires elle entraîne
d'importants coûts économiques pour la
société notamment en termes de dépenses
liées aux consultation médicale au
traitement aux arrêts de travail liés la
douleur chronique à son retentissement
de plus la douleur chronique peut être
coûteuse en raison de l'errance médicale
et des effets néfastes des traitements
inappropriés en effet la douleur
chronique en tant que maladie est encore
largement sous diagnostiqué et
insuffisamment prise en charge par notre
système de santé donc il est essentiel
de prendre en compte l'impact sociétal
de la douleur chronique lors de
l'élaboration de politique de santé